Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the American prison
action thriller film called “Escape Plan.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts in a high-security federal
prison in Colorado.
An inmate named Ray Breslin is approached
by a fellow inmate who warns him about someone
named Jax.
According to him, Jax is about to start a
fight with Ray.
The next day, like the inmate had said, Jax
attacks Ray but is soon overpowered by him.
Ray wins the fight but because of the commotion,
the prison guards put him into the isolation
area of the prison.
It is a high-security area that only the dangerous
inmates are brought into.
Ray is then put into a tiny room with no windows
and only a toilet.
He is also watched upon at all times through
a security camera.
The only possession he is allowed to have
is a bible.
Ray quickly begins to devise a plan to escape
from the prison.
He has already analyzed the layout of the
prison and found that the high-security area
is beside the fire garage.
Next, he notices that the prison is short
on guards which makes his work easier.
For several days, Ray watches the guards and
figures out their regular behavioral pattern
includes going out to smoke for exactly seven
minutes.
With these pieces of information, Ray figures
out what time and way would be the best to
escape from.
Now, he only has to find a way to somehow
get the passcode to his high-security prison
door.
For this, he tears a thin layer of plastic
from the chocolate milk packaging that he
is given with every meal.
He sneakily lays the plastic on the touchpad
and acquires the series of numbers of the
passcode.
With the numbers in hand, it is easy for him
to figure out the sequence.
He also manages to inform his team outside
the prison to create a distraction at exactly
four on the day he will escape.
Finally, he executes the plan one day.
As the guards go for a smoke break, he uses
the passcode to get out of the cell.
Then, through a vent, he enters the unguarded
fire garage.
At this moment, his team causes a fire outside
the prison as a distraction.
The firemen take the fire brigade outside
and Ray manages to go out with them by latching
himself to the bottom of the vehicle.
After finally getting out of the prison, Ray
drives away with his teammates, Abigail and
Hush.
They leave him by the side of a telephone
booth where the police eventually find and
arrest him.
However, before they can take Ray back to
the prison, a man named Lester Clark arrives
at the scene and talks to the guards to let
Ray go.
In the following scene, we see Lester and
Ray talk to the prison head.
It is finally revealed that Ray is actually
the founder of a security firm called Breslin-Clark
that tests the security measures of prisons.
He is not a criminal but a businessman who
goes to several prisons as an inmate to check
if they are escape-proof.
Over the years, he has garnered a reputation
as the man who can escape any prison.
The prison guard is beyond surprised and thankful
for Ray’s feedback on how they can make
the prison’s security better.
After the meeting, Ray goes to his office
for the first time in five months.
He is greeted by his friends and employees,
Abigail and Hush.
His business partner Lester has scheduled
a meeting with CIA operative Jessica Miller.
She wants Ray to test a new, top-secret prison
for disappeared persons on the condition that
Ray and his team cannot know the prison's
true location.
She offers him millions of dollars for the
deal but Ray is skeptical of the idea.
He only agrees to go when his partner Lester
requests him.
They provide him with a fake identity of a
Spanish terrorist-for-hire named "Anthony
Portos."
On the day he is supposed to go to the prison,
Abigail places a tracker on his arm, as per
protocol.
However, things start going south when he
is kidnapped and drugged to be put in prison
so its location remains anonymous.
His abductors also painfully bring out the
tracker from his arm as Ray loses consciousness.
When he wakes up, Ray finds himself in a glass
cell on top of a platform.
Around him are several similar cells with
prisoners in them.
They are being watched through moving cameras.
Ray is then brought to meet the prison warden
Hobbes who introduces himself.
Ray is confused because he was told the prison
warden is a person named Marsh.
Knowing something is off, Ray cites his evaluation
code which is supposed to get him out of the
prison in case of an emergency.
However, the warden completely ignores it
and declares him an inmate.
Outside the prison, Abigail and Hush try their
best to find Ray’s location.
While back in the prison, the inmates are
told to evacuate to the “Babylon” area.
The guards all wear identical masks and are
allowed to hit any inmate they dislike.
A while later, Ray is approached by another
inmate named Emil who warns him to not get
killed.
He also says that he hasn’t committed any
crime and was simply imprisoned because some
people want to get the information about his
boss Mannheim from him.
Ray now starts to believe that this prison
doesn’t hold federal criminals but is a
torture chamber that rich people send their
enemies to.
He plans to investigate further in the isolation
area.
So, Ray and Emil start a fight to be sent
there.
The warden sees this from the cameras and
is almost excited to have them fighting.
Soon, they are sent to the isolation area
which is a tiny room and substitute for a
torture chamber.
The room acts like an oven, with a temperature
higher than a human being can handle.
It is intended to disorient and dehydrate
prisoners with high-powered halogen lights.
The warden watches the two suffer in the heat
through the cameras.
After a day in the chamber, a prison doctor
named Dr. Kyrie visits Ray.
He seems sympathetic to him but doesn’t
answer when Ray asks him their location.
After the session, Emil and Ray are let out
of the room.
During his time in the chamber, Ray has found
out that the cell floors have rivets of steel
instead of more secure aluminum.
So, he asks Emil to acquire a metal plate
that he can use to open the rivets.
On Emil’s next meeting with the warden,
he is asked about his boss Mannheim again.
Emil deliberately makes the warden mad and
guards forcefully shove a water pipe down
his throat.
While he is being tortured, Emil manages to
get a piece of metal.
After the meeting, he demands to know Ray’s
plan in turn for the favor.
Ray reveals that he has been analyzing the
structure of the prison and has come to a
conclusion that the place is underground.
So, if he gets the bolts out and makes his
way upward, he might be able to reach the
surface.
After hearing his plan, Emil believes that
Ray can help him escape.
They quickly execute the plan and start a
fight to be sent back to the isolation chamber.
There, Ray begins to open the rivet while
hiding from the camera.
After he is done, he bangs the chamber to
signal Emil to distract the guards again.
Emil starts to scream making everyone look
at him while Ray blocks his camera with a
paper ball he had in his mouth.
He finally gets into the vent and makes his
way outside.
On his way, he accidentally breaks a pipe
making the chamber fill with water.
When Ray finally gets outside, he is surprised
to see that the prison is in a massive cargo
ship in the middle of the ocean.
He quickly goes back in before anyone can
see him.
The water leak causes the isolation chambers
to flood which distracts the guards and makes
it easy for him to get back without being
caught.
In the following scene, we see Ray’s friends
Abigail and Hush talk to Lester about Ray’s
disappearance.
They see that the check Ray had been provided
for his work has bounced.
Moreover, the woman who offered Ray the job
is out of contact.
They ask Lester to run a search but the man
dismisses them, claiming that Ray is doing
his job.
After the two leave, we see Lester calling
the prison warden and asking him to keep Ray
in the prison for the rest of his life.
It turns out that Lester wants to have the
company to himself and be its sole owner.
So, he had set up the fake deal to get Ray
to the prison and keep him there forever.
However, Abigail and Hush do not give up and
keep looking for Ray.
Hush finds out about an illegal private-owned
prison named the tomb that people put their
enemies in.
It is in fact, the prison that Ray is in but
Hush doesn’t find the prison’s location.
Back in the prison, Ray and Emil start to
analyze the guards’ routine which is difficult
for them because the guards all wear identical
masks.
They do it for several days and figure out
some important details about their schedule.
Now, they have to figure out what part of
the world they are in so they can devise an
escape plan.
For this, Ray tries to ask the prison doctor
for help but he refuses to do so.
Hence, instead, he sneaks out a cardboard
paper to use it as a makeshift sextant and
determine the ship’s latitude.
However, they will have to be on the top of
the deck to make the sextant work.
So, Ray and Emil ask a Muslim inmate Javed
Afridi to help them with the plan.
Later, Javed offers to be the warden’s spy.
In turn, he asks the warden to let him pray
to Allah in the open air.
Not knowing his true intentions, the warden
agrees and lets him go outside.
Afridi then uses the sextant and figures out
the latitude of the ship.
Using this information, Ray deduces that they
are in the Atlantic Ocean near Morocco.
He and Emil are still not sure about the location
but they have to think of a plan soon.
Emil says that he has a friend in Morocco
who owes him big time.
If they somehow get a message to him, he and
his group will surely come to save them.
Ray again meets the prison doctor and persuades
him to help them.
Later at night, the doctor sends Emil’s
friend an email, giving him their location.
It is finally the day they execute the plan.
At first, Afridi gives the warden fake information
about a riot about to happen in block A. The
warden sends all his guards to the block leaving
the Babylon area with only two of them.
Ray sees the right time and starts a riot
in the Babylon area.
Soon, everyone starts fighting in the place
and Ray, Emil, and Afridi take the opportunity
to run to the top of the deck.
The warden notices this and initiates a lockdown
in the cargo.
Before the three can reach the top, the doors
are shut because of the lockdown.
At the same time, Emil’s men also arrive
in their helicopters to save them.
But inside the ship, the guards and the group
get into a shootout.
Afridi gets shot in the process and cannot
move anymore.
Ray quickly thinks of a plan and asks Emil
to stay with Afridi while he goes to the control
room and cuts the power.
This way, the doors to the top of the deck
can reopen.
After he leaves, Afridi asks Emil to leave
without him because he is too injured to make
it out alive.
Emil reluctantly does what the man says.
Sometime later, the guards get to Afridi and
kill him.
But at the same time, Ray manages to shut
the power down, helping Emil get on top of
the deck.
Emil runs to the helicopter which is being
shot by the guards.
Soon, he and his friends retaliate while waiting
for Ray to come out.
Ray, however, is stuck inside the ship in
a tank.
The guards are looking for him everywhere,
so instead of getting out, he flushes himself
into the sea.
Emil’s helicopter takes off and he sees
Ray struggling in the water.
To help him, he throws the helicopter’s
ladder below.
Ray latches onto the ladder and fires at the
oil tanks on the ship.
This causes an explosion that kills the warden
and his men.
At last, the two safely fly away in the helicopter
and land on the Moroccan coast.
A car comes to pick them up and to Ray’s
surprise, Jessica, the woman who had offered
him the job in the prison steps out of it.
He is even more baffled when Emil says she
is his daughter.
It is then revealed that Emil is actually
Mannheim, who everyone thought was his boss.
He had lied about his identity so his enemies
wouldn’t kill him.
Jessica knew her father was in prison so she
had to get Ray imprisoned to get him out.
Before leaving, Jessica tells Ray that his
business partner Lester got involved with
the prison warden and demanded they keep Ray
forever, so he was in fact, betraying him.
In the following scene, we see Ray and Abigail
together.
Abigail informs him that Lester was offered
a job as CEO of the prison if the prototype
Ray was staying in proved to be inescapable.
After knowing that Ray has escaped, Lester
packs his bags to flee.
But Hush and Abigail track him down and put
Ray’s revenge plan into action.
Then, we see Lester being attacked by Hush
in a car.
When the man wakes up, he finds himself still
inside the car but his car turns out to be
in a massive cargo ship traveling to an unknown
destination.
Ray has taken his revenge in his own way.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.